hello and welcome to Zinn you're playing
chess fully just fully okay I want above
2500 again that's good news it's the
wrong move water actually hmm yeah it's
not like bad it's just like when I
played c5 them and it's it's been a
while since I did I usually played it
with a different intention let's say
this is not my my opening my opening
position my type of position
okay Knight see - yeah they play with
Queen a5 and Queen h5 stuff like that
nowadays not really sure
yeah Queen a5 is probably not terrible
no it's taking a good while him Bishop
d2 okay I mean I wanted to go here
anyway yeah one way to handle this for
widest I wanted to say efore now he goes
III III okay not sure why this would be
better than you form
[Music]
okay 94 makes no sense okay let's just
straight not there should be six
yeah it's it has this this has most of
the characteristics of a Maroc see bind
white has this strong point on D 500k
did not expect this move well I will
take it I could take but I'm not certain
what is doing their own D for I mean why
definitely does not want to take on c6
that would make very little sense I mean
at least in terms of playing for
something I mean it's very tough for y
to be versed in such a position you have
to do really really silly things to be
worse so when I say I didn't expect the
move I don't I don't think I'm better or
anything where this really rock solid
okay yeah yeah I want to I want to trade
more pieces this is why I play Bishop
takes he should probably go efore now
even though I'm not sure if those rules
still apply to this position and you
know yeah this is very equal it's very
difficult to get anything going there
pawn takes I guess
[Music]
so what is for what is she doing them
that's it's a bit a bit odd playing like
this
hmm so he doesn't mind you be five it
seems okay
oh maybe I'm not really understanding
this position and he's got some play
with the a pawn I mean I don't quite I
don't quite get it
so look c2 is going okay d2 I guess you
know
okay let's just get the king involved he
currently cannot go a forum how are you
going to get it back
okay so h4 and it's a small weakness
than anything else now the H point that
White has this just is just a midweek so
check and now and it could go group g4
as well have a little attack on the
Bishop it's not having that many good
squares rhythm Andrew cage for of course
trying to pick pick up the porn okay
[Music]
yeah let's try to pick it up keeping
this 124 seconds it's a bit bit it's not
another lot but it's not so difficult to
play this position unfortunately you
just want to invade their I guess not
sure where he is going with this okay
could do the check first not sure if
that helps but let's take this b3 is a
good point to win here threatening
Bishop e5 mate almost it's not made but
close it's still not bad
winning the F porn unfortunately I don't
get the rook somewhere that I can really
play for maid it's a bit bit a bit
annoying my rook is somewhat passive try
to get get it traded
mid let's meet yeah I don't know many
strange many strange things happening so
he had a very solid opening and yeah I
was a bit surprised that III looks like
a very conservative choice the and the
engine likes Bishop g4 I looked at this
but I saw exactly the same position but
I wasn't really certain that this helps
me computer things black is good yeah
like it's fine I'm okay equal yeah I'm
always a bit worried if there are four I
mean the thing is that black does not
have that much space and my experience
in the mirach C point and this is very
related yes you need to trade some
pieces to have space stem that you can
operate on and it's I don't radium so
this is why I was more inclined to take
and this is why I was not at all unhappy
about his operations here that led to
further trades again why does not worse
it's just like I'm absolutely not afraid
at all if it starts to trade down
because that can only be helping me
Sophia Pontius would be more normal but
he took with the rook and there's a
remark in the chat what about b5 20 b5
yeah maybe maybe already Here I am
I thought maybe this one but it is not
it is not really that great rock c6 is
so good move
now here black is fine yeah
so b5 is maybe better even if that's
actually very likely that it is better I
mean here I'm okay
but not not better yeah f5 I think is
yes approved by the comp get the king
close and I was kind of happy to see h5
it just it just doesn't work really I
take and I'm better h4 is one
possibility the engine wants to go
Bishop f6 but this is good the H pawn is
just weak and I'm picking picking some
material up so slowly but but surely
this is going downhill for white I mean
I didn't have much time so I don't
really I cannot be sure that there
wasn't any improvement possible on the
next couple of moves
maybe there was something better but you
know the engine doesn't really find
anything substantial and here I mean
it's the material and it is the position
it's a bit much and here made okay
yeah King on the edge file is better
with the position is already pretty much
pretty much hopeless yeah then the main
thing is that in these types of
positions there you shouldn't trade all
that much the Queen trade isn't even a
big issue it's mostly about minor pieces
like from here he should if possible
just try to keep all the pieces on the
board and then try to expand it's not
that simple actually easier with Queens
on for some reason but it's it's um it's
what you should do like slowly eform h3
f4 just very slowly push forward and any
operations that straight are absolutely
harmless em this is very harmless okay
guys thanks for watching